for some people staying in comfort zone
is not an option people like me want to
explore places and opportunities to
reach our full potential the
postgraduate program in lanx Sigma by
you maath and simply learn help me to do
so by getting an amazing opportunity
here in the United Kingdom with
250% hike and not just that I have
become a global practitioner right now
working with the biggest tech company in
the world and I give due credit to the
certification hey I'm R legaspi and I'm
from the Philippines I did my graduation
back in 2011 and started working the
same year my career has been great I was
working for one of the biggest Financial
firms in the
Philippines however I always wonder what
would it be like to work abroad
and have a global role and so I started
searching I also realized that I needed
to upskill myself I only had green Bel
certification and so that made me take a
step and enroll to the postgrad program
in lan6 Sigma by UMass and simply learn
and I actually do believe that that
simple step changed my life last year I
moved to the United Kingdom I joined one
of the the biggest Tech firms in the
world as a worldwide continuous
Improvement expert they were looking for
someone with Black Belt certification in
L6 Sigma and I really do believe that
the postgraduate program would simply
learn helped me get the job I think that
we get opportunities on a daily basis on
how we can up skill and change our lives
it is in our hands when can we take take
the action and do
it